papile papile
papile papi papile
papi papile papile papile papile papile
papile
papy
[Musique]
il fait beau le soleil
brille si souou et Julien marche
gaiement les hondelles tournent en rond
dans le ciel bleu elles font de grands
cercles nous allons choisir des des
papiers de ton gris
différents et de ton
[Musique]
Beig et nous découpons le corps de
l'Hirondelle 18h 22
18 la forme ressemble un peu à celle que
nous avions découpé pour le
poisson nous regardons la trajectoire
qu'ell suivent pour
tourner
et nous découpons la seconde en essayant
d'épouser cette forme d'aplatir un peu
le ventre d'arrondir un peu plus le dos
pour qu'elle puisse avancer plus
[Musique]
vite la dernière va fermer le
cercle plie un peu son
[Musique]
corps nous la découpons dans du papier
noir 18h 23 30
[Musique]
secondes vous découpez les ailes du
papier bleu
clair de grands demi-cercles
et de bons coups de ciseaux pour qu'elle
file
[Musique]
vite des petits ronds blancs pour les
yeux des triangles pour les
[Musique]
becs des bec nous en avons découpé
souvent des oisillons de
blouse ceuxci sont plus longs et plus
pointus de couleur jaune
[Musique]
orange
vous les faites
avancer elle tourne en rond elle trace
de grands cercles dans le
ciel
[Musique]
18h 2 30
second 18h
[Musique]
secondes
bonsoir